[Music]
hi guys i'm abby roberts and welcome to
my glamour unfiltered
i think because it's kind of like the
anti-social media app i guess it's been
like so many years now that social media
has been so airbrushed and all about
being super polished especially on
instagram it's like all fillers and
facetune and that kind of stuff and i
think youtube as well even got like
super oversaturated and tiktok came
along and it was just so refreshing to
have like a social media where people
show all the behind the scenes i go on
there with my spots out and everything
like you know everyone sees all the
behind the scenes stuff so it's quite
nice to show that side of yourself i
think
[Music]
tick tock has shaped me and educated me
in so many ways i think because it's
filled with like all of these kids from
different subcultures and with that
brings like different aesthetics and
even just viewpoints and stuff like i
feel like i've been educated on issues
that i didn't even know existed so i'm
like super thankful for tick-tock in
that way as well as like just inspiring
me with like my art and stuff i feel
like i really
found like my aesthetic i kind of
struggled with that for a long time like
oh my god who am i and everyone like
around you is always like you need to
know exactly who you are and who you
want to be and i was just like i just
want to dress all these different ways
and i don't have to pick like one thing
but i think tic toc totally embraces
that
i was lucky enough to like surround
myself with some really amazing people
in the beauty industry especially
patrick starr was one of them i think
patrick told me to like get a good team
around me because back then i didn't
really
like
have a manager or anything i was kind of
doing it on my own i'm really lucky that
i found a good punishment
[Music]
i think is probably how like fearless
they are and how we are i guess and not
afraid to
challenge societies like standards and
that kind of stuff um expressing
yourself in the way you dress in the way
you do makeup that's something that i'm
like super passionate about and i've
always just like done whatever makeup i
want to put on my face and i'll go out
in it and don't really care if i like
get stairs or anything and you know it
makes me happy so i do it
[Music]
how i manage my mental health i'm not
gonna lie like i don't
it is uh it's an ongoing struggle i'm
not gonna like like the comments and
stuff that you get um being an
influencer can be pretty brutal
sometimes i think especially on like
social media platforms where you can be
so anonymous people will just speak
their mind and it's something you really
have to be careful about my message to
people who told me not to post videos
online i give them a big
[Music]
i think
it's staying inspired it's something i
struggle with quite a bit because
um there's such an expectation for you
to be like
posting every day and always like
topping your previous video and
something that i learned is to like work
smarter not harder
so now i kind of do a bit of lifestyle a
bit of music bit of
everything that i love
[Music]
are always comments that like prey on
your insecurity i think
um i'd like posted videos in i don't
know revealing outfits or tight fitted
clothing and then people like commenting
on my body you just have to work on
yourself and like being as confident as
you can be in yourself so that it
doesn't let other people's opinions face
you if that makes sense so look after
your own mental health before worrying
about other people's opinions
[Music]
i started going to a therapist but that
kind of really bothered me because the
therapist was like telling me how to
live my life and i got so frustrated at
that and i was like you don't know me or
my situations uh i kind of ghosted my
therapist i'm not gonna lie and then i
haven't seen her in months but i started
going to a new one and
he's much cooler
he kind of doesn't tell me how to live
my life he just lets me vent to him so i
just ran at him for an hour and that's
kind of therapeutic as well i think
um
working on my music is something that
i've found really therapeutic like
getting to prevent those feelings and
emotions
and putting that into songwriting
[Music]
i never really wanted to be like a
beauty guru it's kind of just me
expressing my creativity because of that
people think that i don't do anything
else in my spare time i guess but um
i've actually been working on music
i'm so glad to be talking about this
because it's been on the low for a while
now but i've been working on it for like
the past year i'm like if i can do this
with makeup i was at makeup when i was
11 years old let me tell you if you
watch that youtube video of me do my
sister's makeup it is terrible i believe
that if i put in the hours and the
dedication that i could be a good
musician and i'm very proud to say that
the songs i'm coming out with
they're kind of fired i'm not gonna lie
i definitely feel pressured to speak up
on certain issues and it's not something
that like i shy away from because
there's absolutely
a bunch of things that i'm super
passionate about one of those is like
standing up for lgbtq people
um
i owe so much to that community because
it was like how i got into doing the
crazy kind of makeup that i do you know
i grew up watching rupaul's drag race
and was like so inspired by all the drag
queens and it was that crazy kind of
makeup that
led me into doing the wild makeup that
i'm kind of known for
i think the message that i really want
to put across with my platform is
just encouraging self expression and
boldness and i think everything that i
do like content-wise hopefully does that
i know that so many people have told me
that you know me showing my makeup stuff
online encourage them to like start
their own makeup page and it like melts
my heart that people that that is how
they feel after just watching my videos
i think sometimes i get so sucked into
just being in my little bubble and doing
my makeup and not thinking that it
really does anything but when people
have stories like that it really like
makes me so happy
[Music]
the ability to communicate i think that
social media like tick tock has brought
so many people together that like would
never have interacted before you know
you might meet someone you're from the
uk and you're meeting someone from
america and even me personally like a
lot of my best friends from social media
from like the us and all over the world
and
allowing like people from different
communities to have those kind of
discussions i think really
um brings like unique opinions and makes
people want to stand up for what they
believe in
i would probably say in like a business
sense i'm very set on like what i want
to do and who i will and won't work with
everything has to be has i feel like
super genuine to me especially when it
comes to like brand deals and that kind
of stuff as an influencer you get ripped
into doing that kind of stuff a lot and
i'm really cautious about who i do and
don't work with i only work with like
brands who i really genuinely love
their products and that kind of stuff
[Music]
setbacks i think for me is usually
burning out i'm really bad at like
overworking and i don't really know when
to stop
and that actually happened the other
month i ended up in hospital um
because i was
i was working and working and working in
my mind i'm like i can work through this
and my body is like
no you can't
so i ended up um in hospital
they said it was like stress or whatever
causing my heart to do all sorts of
funky things um
but i think that was a real like
realization moment for me that i need to
take time to myself so
i've been making that kind of a mission
lately it's just to set aside and
actually like schedule time for me and
to do things that i like
i think
as a young creator i often get looked
down upon for being like a woman and
being young and people think that
because i'm so young and i'm a
tick-tocker or influencer or whatever
that i don't have a brain and i'm not
like a business woman but that is
something that i'm really passionate
about i've been doing social media since
i was 11 years old and i always knew
what i wanted to do and this was not an
accident
like i've been working at this for a lot
of years i do know what i'm doing i have
a vision of myself where i want to be my
goals for the future and i'm going to
make it happen and you can too
you